what were some of his rebuttals I I've
watched the energy yeah but remind me
okay I would say most of his rebuttals I
think what he's trying to stand on is
trying to have a balanced conversation
right so he looks at people who are in
The Red Pill space is imbalance uh I
don't think that's an authentic argument
because we're content creators as well
so if you want balance I mean I think
what do what you're trying to do is tell
me the torpedo my lane and my channel
what are you trying to tell me to do
because we get we can have a balanced
conversations by having two different
opinions
but my opinion is this like so if I'm if
I'm saying my channel is about Ferraris
and then you want me to tell me you
drive to work tomorrow
yeah I interviewed him the next day okay
okay
so look i i people he should know how
content works right yeah that's where
he's authent he's not authentic because
he knows how this works
and now you're telling me to be balanced
based on your interpretation of how it
works but that's not a that's not the
conversation that we have on social
media I think people
tend to subscribe to channels
that have a certain message
period now if you go off that if I
invite you into my channel and say this
is what we're talking about and the next
day I flip
to try to have a balanced conversation
that's not authentic but then his
argument is well you're only doing it
for the money look this is how social
media works you know what what are we
doing here are we going to have our
authentic conversation about how social
media works or you want a balanced
conversation but it can't be both
what do you think do you think men
should get married today
should men get married it depends on
your position so I tell men and uh a lot
of people get this wrong they think I'm
against marriage
as a principal that's wrong I'm against
state-sponsored marriage and I'm against
men getting married without information
most men get married both right they get
married stay sponsored and they think
they're getting married under God or
they get married in the church or from
their community and they're not anymore
okay it's state sponsored then most men
get married when they're in a position
where they can't
uh provide whatever they need to provide
to the to the wife of the marriage and
then that's how they get divorced
so they get married and they have
nothing they have nothing but love so we
have love our love is like no other love
are you saying that doesn't last
love yeah love is love does not last
it's not intended to last
love is not attended the last actually
most people even people who are pushers
of Love Will Tell You Love lasts 18
months maybe three years
but this is why it's important that you
actually have something else to build on
other than love but if you want to make
your decision purely on love what
happens when the love ends
and then you're going to have to deal
with that so this is why children are
important right so if you have love love
is basically basically lust
confusing you to procreate that's nature
it gets this attachment it feels good I
hope everybody experiences it's great as
you get older it's less and less for for
men you'll experience it less and less
this is just how it works I think that's
true for everyone
like yeah
they use love to manipulate men into
marrying them when they're when they've
already been ran through
so this is the pair bonding argument so
they'll say but but I love you but you
need Brent to be paid yeah that's what
it is or it's like that was
um
yeah that's what people girls get so mad
on my show when they say that what I
love that like this no no no no not that
like the pair bonding oh the pair
bonding yeah yeah but I'm like I don't
it's like they tell on themselves though
because they're so angry yeah like why
are you this why are you this man you
shouldn't be Rebecca you shouldn't be
this man well the proof is in the
pudding all I say is just look at the
results that we have out here if you
have for women unfortunately if your
sexual partners pass a certain number
what you're doing is manipulating it's
not love there's no way it could be
loved now you can be attached people
have to understand loving attachment are
two different things and you can tell by
when the relationship ends if you had an
attachment or love see a person that had
love they'll be have their feelings hurt
and then they'll be indifferent to the
person they may be like well I just want
but a person that had an attachment is
like a parasite they'll try to kill the
person they'll hate the person after
they broke the attachment because the
ego is involved there was never any love
what they'll do is they'll go attack the
person
yeah it's like a parasite parasitic
relationship so once the once the host
shakes the parasite off the parasite
hates the host right
that's that's attachment and so if they
loved them because he I almost think
like okay because when I think of girls
like I feel like the girl if she hates
her act she still loves him
yeah because you don't like I feel like
hate is closer to love
than than like I feel like if a girl
doesn't talk about him like then she
didn't care okay so but but I my
rebuttal of that is you don't destroy
something you love
typically if there's hate involved she's
trying to destroy embarrassing them
that's ego so what she'll do is drag him
through the divorce court take him to
child support trying to penalize him and
hurt him take the kids away don't let
them see the kids that that's not that
don't come from love that come from Pure
as parents
I don't know anyone that's been divorced
but I'm just thinking like like in in my
eyes
and my in my friend group I know like
older people but I wasn't kind of young
I guess you know what I'm saying
the what the junior college but my
audience
what is it junior college is a young
woman
typically under the age of 25 between
the ages of primarily 18 and 26 is your
Junior College age
yeah
they'll know they'll be in the comment
section okay okay I did with the junior
I graduated but you know no you still
Junior College oh no I'm graduated it
doesn't matter oh okay a lot of people
still in school
okay okay so
um the what were we talking about I got
her shuffling now all right so we were
talking about you never seen you never
divorced but I'm thinking like
I feel like
if a girl hates like if she's like I
hate my ex
I'm like no you still love him I guess
younger women would probably have that
because they have the ability to pair
bonds to you yeah right they have that
pair bond or she's been imprinted by
that man so she hates him but there's a
reason why and you have to figure that
out she hates him because she lost them
she hates them because
um he won't give her advantages and let
her manipulate you have to figure out
what that is but because you're dealing
with a younger group of women they still
haven't these are the first few men that
they've been with so yeah the hate can
be generally come from love it could be
that Dynamic once they're older than
that 26 it comes from Pure manipulation
and and uh trying to penalize a guy yeah
yeah man that women evolved man you got
to take that you got to take that man
women evolve as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible